sur ce sujet de la migration
typiquement c'est un sujet qui n'es
traité que s'ils arrivent un drame que
si on peut le prendre sous l'angle de
l'émotion il faut faire quelque chose
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui s'est passé en
Biélorussie d'un seul coup les caméras
se braque sur l' arrivée de migrants au
milieu de la forêt on sait pas d'où il
venait ce qui s'est passé on fait pour
les
amener et comment ça s'est passé mais
c'est dire que si les choses bougent
c'est uniquement parce que il va y avoir
un intérêt négatif parce que c'est
dramatique or l'émigration illégal elles
sont légion quotidienne il y a eu la
Roya auparavant chaque point de
rencontre entre frontière fait ce genre
de Seine et une fois qu'ils arrivent le
drame alors là on s'y intéresse et les
politiques s'y intéresse et tu dois
faire les choses que je vois là c'est
que on a des politiques c'est la
République en marche et on a un Gérald
Darmanin qui sort des choses assez
terrible on écoute la vidéo où il parle
des migrants qui utilisent les bébés
pour ne pas se faire arrêter en mer
et dans l'image très récente que j'ai lu
publié notamment dans les journaux
anglais dans une partie des journaux
anglais où on voit des policiers qui
voient partir à bateau et une partie 1
partie seulement de la politique
britannique elle veut dire dès que font
les policiers français laisse partir des
bateaux nous vous disons que dans cette
image date qu'on a pas vu c'est que les
migrants utiliser des bébés et les
menaces et de les jeter dans une eau à
quelques degrés sur un moteur s'il
venait les appeler maintenant ces cas-là
je leur dire le mot intérieur la
consigne c'est de ne pas intervenir ne
pouvons pas mettre en danger la vie
d'enfant de billard qui sont basculé
parfois dans la mer c'est un constat que
malheureusement les policiers français
font depuis de nombreuses années parce
que les gens ont envie d'aller en
Grande-Bretagne
c'est pas du tout la version d'un
rescapé d'un naufrage qui disait que les
SOS envoyé au gars de Claude Français
ont été reçu avec dédain en disant qu'il
fallait appeler du côté anglais